[Music]
one of my favorite performances of yours
is in Dracula
yes Bram Stoker's Dracula I thought you
were absolutely amazing and like
redefined you that role how do you
prepare for a role like Dracula you know
there's there anything you can do as an
actor as a serious actor to prepare to
play Dracula well you had you had the
the other cast members we rehearsed for
four weeks in in Napa Valley with with
Coppola Francis Ford Coppola yeah and
and they went off and did various things
for research but I said - I said to
Francis is it well what you know what do
I do because I'm 300 years old and I'm
dead right you know there's how do you
how do you prepare for that reality
right but when I got back to when I got
back to California Oh California when I
got back to Los Angeles he sent me over
a coffin which I kept in the inn in the
garage I think he wanted me to have sex
in it Francis Ford Coppola wanted you to
have sex coffee
to prepare the place I think you cut it
kind of hinted at it you said did you
get the coffin it's still a big
extrapolation to have sex in it when I
say hey did you get the cookies I said
over
I don't assume that you've had sex with
that you're not although you're gonna
use the jar
you get those cookies so so I had a KY
at this coffin and so I removed the car
from the garage put the [ __ ] put the
confident in the garage and then one on
a wild at night this is back in the day
back when you join your crazy time yeah
when I was when I was a drinker back in
the day I these girls people just ended
up at the house and when they were
leaving I you know I wanted to impress
them and I had a little switch inside
the house and the garage door would open
and the light would come on over the
coffin and I said I said hey girls you
know Jeff you know check this out and
the thing and they went oh my god yeah
when they never came back now I think
they don't come back after that
you